cómo
buenos días viajes buenos días muchas
gracias por estar con nosotros este año
en cannes viene con muchas novedades ya
que está aquí por tres películas tienen
una agenda muy cargada
sí pero estoy muy contento por las
películas he venido a presentar tres
películas dos que aún no he visto una
que sí vi porque es mi película y estoy
muy contento con estas películas por
varias razones la primera porque es una
película de pietro marcello llamada
lenbur me había encantado la anterior
maldad en que fue presentada en venecia
e inmediatamente cuando vi la película
me dije él es realmente muy muy original
por el tipo de cine que se podría decir
que hay directores que hacen películas
realmente modernas o posmodernas o
vanguardistas y su manera de ser moderno
es volviendo a una forma primitiva se
podría decir porque mezcla imágenes de
archivo y el hecho de que venga francia
el que es un director napolitano además
tiene un imaginario casi ruso porque es
un gran espectador de películas rusas e
italianas y a mí me encantan los
italianos siempre es sueño trabajar con
italianos tuve la oportunidad de hacerlo
hace dos años así que me alegró mucho
trabajar con él y además nos hicimos
casi amigos
[Música]
sí
así para ti
habla de mí
esta película abre la quincena de
realizadores una selección paralela que
se creó después de mayo del 68 para
mostrar películas de todos los
horizontes y a veces con cineastas aún
desconocidos su padre philip jagger
estuvo en la quincena presentó una
película aquí hay muchos cineastas que
vinieron fassbinder vino mucho a
presentar su trabajo que eran películas
que no correspondían a la selección de
películas oficiales de cannes que estaba
más centrada en el underground o en la
vanguardia así que la quincena de
realizadores era para mostrar todo este
trabajo significa algo para usted que
una película en la que ha participado
sea seleccionada en la quincena de
realizadores y siempre porque mis
mejores recuerdos de khan quizás porque
era más joven ingenuo o no sé son de una
película de christophe honoré que se
llama dan pub y que presentamos en la
quincena de realizadores
creo que todo fue encantador la
proyección salió bien me encantó la
película me encantó ghandouri con quien
actúe así que tengo muy buenos recuerdos
de esa edición de la quincena de
realizadores
su otra novedad esta vez en la
competencia es la película de valeria
bruni tedeschi le damos una película
sobre vacas ya no es así patricia ahora
el director del teatro a mandiá que
estaban ante él y un día dijo voy a
crear una escuela voy a seguir
dirigiendo obras de teatro pero quiere
estudiantes voy a hacer un concurso de
jóvenes aprendices de actor voy a
seleccionar a unos cuantos y a estos
estudiantes los voy a hacer trabajar y
los voy a dirigir y todo va a funcionar
junto el teatro otros actores que
vendrán a representar obras en nantes
porque no sólo estaban las producciones
de patricia no y esa es una época mítica
para mí que también vengo del teatro
valeria fue alumna de patricio en la
segunda promoción de la escuela
delantera así que siempre he oído hablar
de esta escuela entonces cuando me dijo
voy a hacer una película con jóvenes de
20 años y voy a hacer una película sobre
la escuela delantera cuando me dijo
quieres que tratemos que interpretes a
patricio al principio me daba muchísimo
miedo porque es una especie de no voy a
decir dios pero casi es un poco como
para quienes adoran para mí es padrísimo
y entonces dijimos con valeria no vamos
a limitar el personaje no vamos a hacer
el biopic estándar digamos que hacemos
una impresión de patricio sería una
impresión de patricia
[Música]
calma
para que se
nos oiga
además presenta su cuarto largometraje
fuera de concurso y como director está
aquí con un doble rol en linux o actuar
con justicia puede hablarnos de esta
película lino sound es una película que
dirige y en la que actúe con rodeos y
james al núcleo berg y noemí maryland
para mí es un cruce de tres géneros
película policiaca de robos comedia
romántica y comedia así que es casi una
película policíaca familiar porque la
película empieza y mi personaje se
entera por su mamá de que se va a casar
de que se enamoró de alguien que está en
la cárcel
espero que la película sea graciosa pero
hasta ahora sólo la he visto con unas
pocas personas en las salas de
proyección así que siento mucha presión
porque es la primera vez que una
película que he dirigido se proyecta en
la sala lumière de mujer en la sala
línea
muchas gracias mi viaje el por sacar
tiempo de su apretada agenda para
nosotros para mí es un placer muchas
gracias y que tenga un gran festival de
cannes